foreign
Libby has a question for us it's
interesting to hear jfm often mention
links to their other works but still say
advertisements suck busted is there a
distinction ruined
is there a distinction between
advertisements from large Industries
versus small businesses all right I'm
sitting on my soapbox here
here's what I'll say no there's not a
distinction in fact I will say that I
actually prefer advertisements from
large corporations because they're at
least they tend to put some resources
into those so they're they're a little
more interesting and aesthetically
appealing absolutely entertaining even
yeah sometimes they even throw in like
the random message of like you know like
you brought up the other day where it
brought up the chess player had nothing
to do with the product but they're like
hey here's a chess player you didn't
know about go learn more about this
chess player yeah and so I will say
simply a blanket statement
advertisements suck unfortunately we
conflate advertisement with marketing or
promotion and so when Ryan and TK and I
talk about a book that we wrote or we
talk about something we've created for
other people to find Value in that is
not an advertisement we have an essay on
our web website I would encourage you to
read the full thing I'm certainly not
going to read the whole thing because
it's like 15 pages but it's called can
we have an honest conversation about
advertisements we'll put a link to this
in the show notes and the reason this is
so important to me is because I think
people don't understand the distinction
between advertisement and marketing or
promotion and so here's what the uh
here's how the essay goes if the
following screed were a peer-reviewed
journal article it's abstract would be
brief
advertisements suck well at least most
of them do that's not to say that all
advertising is inherently evil or even
bad because not all advertisements are
created equal they run the gamut from
informative to downright destructive to
understand the inherent problems with
advertisements it's important to first
point out that advertising isn't the
same thing as marketing though these two
terms are often used interchangeably
they are different in practice
advertisements are paid announcements
via a public medium mattress commercials
infomercials for the latest exercise fad
and seemingly harmless adverts for
harmful prescription drugs and they are
generally not indoor an endorsement by
the platform on which they are displayed
so an example of that if all of a sudden
we cut to a break right now and we're
talking about
viagra pills or we're talking about
mattresses or underwear someone is
paying us to talk about those things
right so that's what an advertisement is
in Latin advert air means to turn toward
and that's exactly the aim of today's ad
agencies they're willing to pay heaps of
money to turn your eyes toward their
products and services and if the demand
for a product isn't as high as the
supply no problem advertising can create
a false demand if the budget is high
enough in recent years worldwide
spending on Advertising has topped half
a trillion dollars even writing the full
number 500 comma zero zero zero comma
zero zero zero comma zero zero zero
period zero zero commas and all doesn't
come close to truly understanding its
depth so let's put it into perspective
if you leave your home today and begin
spending one dollar every single second
it will take you more than 15
000 years to spend half a trillion
dollars in fact if you would have spent
a million dollars every single day since
the fall of Rome you still wouldn't have
spent half a trillion dollars by now and
so this is every year we're spending
half a trillion dollars on advertising
and we're spending more than that every
year on Advertising every year which
isn't so bad in and of itself after all
it's just money being spent on informing
people about useful stuff right
yes that sort of used to be true and
then I go into this essay a history of
advertising sort of when it became more
pernicious during the uh turn of the
20th century and as we started
increasing the demand
by trying to get people to buy more
things they didn't need the essay goes
on to talk about the overreach of
advertisers how we really capitalize on
the insecurity of people and so when I
say advertisements suck it's because
quite often these advertisers are paying
to be on large platforms
to make you feel more insecure so you'll
vote a particular way so you'll buy a
product or service so that you will
enrich a corporation or an individual
and the only way that they see that they
can do that is to make you feel
inadequate because if you feel perfectly
whole and complete
then you don't have a need for their
product or service another thing that
advertisers do there's a whole section
here about selling scarcity and so act
now
limited time only while supplies last
these advertised or induced artificial
limits are almost always imaginary you
know it's funny when you go see like the
you drive by car dealership and it's
like big sale and it's like well the
sale wasn't yesterday like what changed
from yesterday that all of a sudden this
car is five thousand dollars cheaper
well it's that maybe they got more
inventory in stock there there are
things that that companies will do but
generally it has to do with they have a
particular quota that they're trying to
meet and so they create artificial
scarcity
I would also say that advertisers are
really good at selling non-essentials
and making them feel as though they're
essential right so they sell us trash
until it's good for us literally since
American farmers are faced with
unprecedented hordes of soybean and corn
crops and thus unprecedented waste
products from those crops advertisers
have found a way not to safely dispose
of the waste but to repackage it and
sell it to you as hydrogenated oil a
supposed alternative to healthier oil
oils from avocados olives almonds Etc
and so that's really just the the tip of
the iceberg because the junk food that
sold to us I mean most of the
commercials for food aren't for food
they're for food like products right
processed foods and of course
uh inflammatory oils like seed oils that
are making us sick also advertising to
children which
is probably the most Insidious of all of
the advertisements but advertisers have
found the easiest way to flood our homes
with non-essentials by advertising to
our children not only do kids lack the
critical thinking skills to say no to
the foods that are killing us but if
they develop brand loyalty early then
Ronald McDonald has a lifetime customer
according to the American psychology
Association commercial appeals to
Children became commonplace with the
Advent and widespread adoption of
television and they grew exponentially
with the proliferation of cable
television which allowed programmers to
develop entire channels of child
oriented programming and advertising
it's 12 billion dollars a year right now
that is used to advertise to the youth
just in America now in the essay it goes
it talks about the upside of advertising
as well it is possible for advertisers
to inform us
and uh then I talk about the preferences
of people like Sao Paulo for example
which we covered I believe on the last
podcast episode during the advertisement
suck segment but Sao Paulo Outlaw
outlawed Billboards all throughout the
country because people voted on hey this
is this is litter our city has become
littered with advertisements and we want
to we want to get out of it and so
all right the article goes into
um profit the profit motive alternatives
to advertisements there's no free lunch
every hour of network television is
peppered with nearly 20 minutes of
interruptions and the same is true for
most other mediums which one would argue
is more costly than the free Price Tag
we're giving up for our two most
precious resources our time and our
attention to receive the product so we
often think oh that podcast is free oh
it's free to turn on the TV and watch
that show but if it's 20 minutes of ads
you're paying with your time and your
attention this is why and I talk about
this in the essay why I always opt for
the premium service when possible if a
Spotify then get rid of the ad supported
version if you can afford it when I say
afford it I don't just mean with your
money but I can't afford to spend my
time on your products and so whenever I
can remove ads from something Dan Savage
one of my favorite podcasts he has a
public version kind of like us and a
it's by the way that's how I got minimal
versus maximal he has a micro versus
Magnum edition of his podcast it's a sex
advice show and what I realized is oh
yeah so he has the ad supported free
public version and then he has the paid
for subscription model and it's just ad
free and it's twice as long
wow I would prefer to pay to not get ads
I pay YouTube twelve dollars a month I
never see an ad on YouTube now right and
now this is from a place of privilege
and I fully recognize I have the
privilege of paying 12 a month to get
rid of those ads but what I will say is
that there are other mediums that I
simply just have opted out of because I
don't have that option that's another
place of privilege I can opt out I can
say no because you are bombarding me
with your advertisements ultimately I
just want to finish this essay here by
talking about marketing because this is
what what we do with our podcast yes we
talk about products and services things
that we create I teach a writing class I
talk about that I don't do
advertisements Ryan and I have never
done an advertisement for any of our
books and later during the advertisement
suck segment I have the most
disappointing ad of my entire life
we'll talk about that in a moment but
let's talk about marketing the flip side
of advertising isn't the absence of
communication it's marketing so when I
say advertisements suck I'm not saying
we need to get rid of all communication
no of course not there's a better way to
do it in his book The mindset of
marketing Derek sivers writes don't
confuse the word marketing with
advertising announcing spamming or
giving away branded crap
really marketing just means being
considerate
marketing means making it easy for
people to notice you relate to you
remember you and tell their friends
about you what sivers is describing here
is the most honest form of marketing
informing people without manipulating or
bothering them at its ethical Zenith
marketing considers the needs and points
and points of view of an audience and
works hard to meet those needs by
connecting the creators with consumers
in an authentic way in neutral terms
marketing is an unpaid endorsement Often
by the Creator herself communicated
directly to an audience who's eager to
learn more about the product or service
when done well this is what Seth Godin
describes as permission marketing the
privilege not the right of delivering
anticipated personal and relevant
messages to people who actually want to
get them it is possible to engage in
world-class marketing without spending a
penny on Advertising true both
advertising and marketing are forms of
promotion both allow creators to present
their goods and services to a group of
people and when executed poorly even
well-intended marketing can be Overkill
like advertisements not all marketing
messages are created equal
unfortunately not every marketer is a
paragon of Integrity just like the
advertising World marketing messages can
be laced with misinformation
exaggerations and propaganda as the
minimalists we provide loads of high
quality free Creations essays podcasts
and quotes and we occasionally use our
platforms to promote a book event or
service and if we're being forthright
even though we attempt to Market with
Integrity even we struggle to walk the
line between informative and Overkill
when I say that I'm not saying that
we're ever beating anyone over the head
but I'm constantly talking to everyone
on the team about we don't want to beat
people over the head with promotional
messages with marketing with promotions
Etc obviously we don't do advertising
but even when we're promoting something
I want to do it Tastefully in a way that
adds value to other people's lives and
while we won't accept a dollar to
advertise on our podcast will happily
recommend things that have added value
to our lives that's what the whole added
value it's a spirit of the added value
segment on our podcast is hey really
getting value from this it's not
sponsored by anyone so you can know that
we actually get value from it yeah and
Libby I don't want you to I don't want
you to think that it it goes unnoticed
with us that everything we do is steeped
in irony so when we say advertisements
suck but we're talking about something
we're doing yeah that's a little ironic
I get what you're saying but to Josh's
point I mean we're promoting something
that we created that we truly truly
believe in and there are products that
we've actually talked about where they
have come to us and they're like hey we
heard you mention this product on your
podcast can we work out some kind of you
know advertisement thing well you know
paid promotion thing and we're like no
because then we have to talk about it we
don't want to have to talk about
anything that's right it's also the
reason we don't monetize our YouTube
channel
by the way that would extend our reach
significantly by monetizing it and it
allows you know more because what
happens is YouTube puts you more in
their algorithms if they're running a
bunch of ads on your videos and
understandably so they're a business
they're allowed to do that I'm not I'm
grateful that YouTube gives us a
platform to Simply upload a video yeah
and I'm not entitled to anything it
cracks me up when I hear creators
YouTubers say oh I've been demonetized
I've been restricted what
YouTube's given you a platform for free
right to upload 4K video you don't have
to pay a hundred thousand dollars for a
server I get to just upload my videos
how awesome is that but I'm not going to
monetize the channel why because how
awful would it be to place ads on the
art that we create because to me this is
our audio art and I don't want a
McDonald's ad I don't want a Pepsi ad I
don't want a KFC ad I don't want an
underwear ad I don't want a
pharmaceutical ad on our podcast and so
what we do is we opt out yes we opt out
of the money but then we simply say hey
if you want to support our show you can
do that patreon.com the minimalists you
can support us you can keep the show 100
advertisement free dude we are steeped
in this economy we are steeped in this
uh this economy of advertisements and
you know listening to you read that
essay I'm like Jesus Christ it sounds
really hopeless like it's just
everywhere you can't get away from it
you know but then I'm certain I'm
starting to think first off like oh how
can we change the system right because
I'm a big idea guy and then I'm like
there's no way there's no way that like
the three of us could change this system
this system is it's been it is like full
blast right now but what we can do is we
can decide on a day to day
on a on a minute by minute hour by hour
we can decide what we do with our time
and who we give our attention to and
because we do come from a place of
privilege where we have this platform to
talk to millions of people
um we also have the opportunity to
decide what we are feeding people or
what we're not feeding people so uh yeah
anyone out there feeling a little
helpless about living in a an economy
like this um you you do have ways to opt
out yourself
both of you guys use the word privilege
so I've got to say something that's very
important because privilege comes up a
lot in discussions on minimalism right
this is a message for the privilege
that's the kind of stereotype
every year
young people from economically
disadvantaged backgrounds and poor
families are given the opportunity to
receive free money in the form of credit
cards with really high interest rates
unbeknownst to them
using those credit cards will cause them
to mortgage their future and become debt
slaves for the next decade
they're not going to use those credit
cards to invest in anything because most
of them don't have the financial
literacy to even know what to invest in
but more importantly you're not likely
to find an investment vehicle that can
outpace the interest rate that you'll
have to give back to the bank in
exchange for that credit card
which means that even if they don't come
from a background where they have a lot
of money or have a lot of stuff they are
so infected with consumerism that when
they receive these credit cards they are
literally going to trade in the next
decade of their lives by spending money
they don't have to buy stuff where does
that mindset come from come from it
comes from a culture that teaches them
how to consume without teaching them how
to create the advertisements that tell
you to buy this or that you'll be happy
if you get this they're not telling you
how to live a lifestyle or how to train
your mind to become the kind of Creator
who solves problem for problems for
people or creates wealth for society
they're just telling you what you need
to buy in order to become wealthy that
is something that infects the minds of
the rich and the poor alike and I would
argue I'm not going to make the full
case here I would argue that it hurts
the poor more I would argue that
consumer culture affects the people who
don't have stuff and who can't afford
stuff even more yeah
um
anyway
I I just had a comment on that really
quickly but I I would say there's
nothing wrong to get to this this uh
question or this concern there's nothing
wrong with accepting a paycheck in
exchange for promoting something as long
as you do it in good faith and with good
with Clarity of conscience but that's
qualitatively different from promoting
something that you yourself created or
you yourself consumed and you want to
share with the rest of the world why
because you can't accept a paycheck
without also accepting accountability to
the person or party that you're
accepting a paycheck from and so if
someone is paying me to promote their
orange juice their gym shoe or their
book they get to have a say and it's
only fair
on not only what I say when I'm
promoting the product but what I say in
the entire context in order to make sure
that it's compatible with the image and
brand that I'm promoting so there is no
such thing as accepting advertising
Revenue without also accepting
accountability to The Advertiser and
most people today have sold their souls
not for money in exchange to go kill
somebody or do something really evil
most people have sold their souls in
exchange for the right to laugh at what
they think is funny the right to speak
what they think is true and most people
are walking around not saying what they
really feel or what they really think
because they've sold out there's nothing
wrong with selling but when it leads to
you selling your soul then that's the
problem and for many people that's
precisely what advertising does to them
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon dot com slash the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]